In the sixth year after Hijrah
year six after Hijrah
on the 10th of Muharram, so at the very
beginning of the year
our prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
chose a companion
a man by the name of Muhammad ibn
Maslamah
and he
made him
the
commander
over a battalion
of troops
that he sent
to quell some rebellious
some rebellious tribes in al-Yamamah
in the area of Najd.
We know Najd so Najd in the Arabic
language, it's not just Najd that is the
area or town it's actually a major city
in Saudi now. It's called Najd that area
or that county, if you will, that is
just a portion of Najd in the time of
the prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
[Arabic recitation]
is an area that is a raised high
elevation area in the Arab Peninsula
that stretches all the way from the
borders of Yemen
all the way up to the borders of Iraq.
This whole area is referred to as Najd.
And so there is a northern Najd and
there's a southern Najd.
The prophet
in this particular incident sent
Muhammad ibn Maslamah with a battalion
of troops to go and quell some of the
rebellion of the tribes of Bani Bakr
out there in the area of Al-Yamamah. So
it is southern Najd. Al-Yamamah is
around the
close to the borders of Yemen. Do we
remember Al-Yamamah? Have we ever heard
of that before?
Al-Yamamah. Who is from Al-Yamamah?
Which character is from Al-Yamamah?
Huh?
Musaylimah al-Kazzab.
He's from Al-Yamamah, right? And he used
to refer to himself as Rahman of
Al-Yamamah.
So this is before the emergence of the
false prophet known as Musaylimah
al-Kazzab. He emerged in the 10th year
after Hijrah. He's got a very
interesting story as well that one day
we will discuss. So he sends this
battalion of troops out there and
[Arabic recitation]
successful.
And they took a man into custody, and
this man's name was Thumāma ibn Uthal.
Thumāma is not just any guy.
This was a major chieftain of Banu
Hanifa.
And this was a huge breakthrough for the
Muslim mean. Why? Because it's not just
the leverage that they have
with respect to
Thumāma. That's one aspect, but
most of the grains,
you know, wheat, barley,
these things, those grains would come up
from Al Yaman through Banu Hanifa. They
were the importers of those things.
So, they were the ones that controlled
this
this delivery system, if you will,
over the years to get these grains up
into the northern regions of the Arab
Peninsula.
So, they controlled a lot.
As a matter of fact, Banu Hanifa could
cause
a famine all on their own, and they have
before.
And so,
this was instrumental. Banu Hanifa were
very close with the people of Mecca, the
chieftains of Mecca. They were thick as
thieves, as they say.
And in some narrations, it's mentioned
that Thumāma was intending to swing by
Al Madinah on his way to Mecca,
you know, as a kind of side quest to
kill the prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam.
These were his intentions.
Initially, he wanted to go for Umrah.
Remember, this is in the month of
Muharram. It's one of the holy months,
one of the sacred ones.
But he had other intentions as well.
And so when Muhammad ibn Maslamah and
his troops took Thumamah, they brought
him back to Medina with them.
And they tied him to one of the pillars
in the masjid.
And
why did they do this? This is a prisoner
of war.
And he is also you know, they didn't
have jail cells, they didn't have a
place to put him. The Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam instructed that he be
tied to one of the pillars in the
masjid.
And so he was.
And Sahih al-Bukhari
Abdullah ibn Yusuf narrates that
al-Layth
Abu Hurayrah tells us that when Thumamah
was tied to the sariya there, the
ustuwana in the masjid,
the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
came to him.
And he said to him,
What do you have to say for yourself?
What What are we going to do here?
Basically, and I'm paraphrasing
the spirit of what he said, right? What
are we going to do here?
And so Thumamah said,
[Silence]
He said, "If you kill me, if you want to
shed my blood,
my blood is not cheap.
I have
men that will avenge me.
And if you
want to forgive me,
overlook, release me,
then you will release someone that will
show appreciation in the future. I'll
owe you.
And if you want money,
ask whatever price you want.
So, the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam left him there.
Left him tied to the pillar.
Everybody went home.
Thumamah is in the masjid tied up.
The next day,
the prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
came to him again, same time. He said,
"Ma indak ya Thumamah?"
What are we going to do here, Thumamah?
He said,
"Kama qultu laka
in tun'im tun'im ala shakir. Lahazul
lafz. Haza lafz al-Bukhari.
Al-ula
[Arabic recitation]
Allah. Arafa anna ha'ula' laysu
ashab intiqam
fi abath.
[Arabic recitation]
Hazul ashab afw.
You know, he changed his tune a little
bit.
The first day, he mentioned three
things. You want to kill me,
don't think that that's going to go
unnoticed. My men, my people are going
to come for you. They're not going to
let that go.
But if you forgive me, you'll forgive
someone who owes you, someone that will
thank you. And if you want money, ask me
whatever price you want.
And so, the next day,
his tune changed a little bit.
He only said,
"I said yesterday,
if you forgive me,
you will forgive someone or if you
forgive, you will forgive someone who
will be thankful. He only mentioned that
part.
Now, notice, why is he being tied in the
masjid? Are there not other places to
keep prisoners of war? Were all
prisoners of war tied in the masjid? No.
This is a very rare instance. Prisoners
of war are usually given into slave
slavery.
When prisoners of war are taken, they're
distributed with the spoils of war. They
are considered property.
And they're distributed and they have
masters now. Whoever was in that battle,
soldiers, horsemen, whatever it is,
they will get a portion of that and
prisoners of war are of that portion.
So, each person is watching that
prisoner and second of all, each person
is being benefited by that prisoner.
They are doing something. They are a
slave now. They work, they cook, they
teach, right? If they have skills,
they're not just sitting in a prison
rotting.
And so,
this is a very specific instance where
he had him tied in the masjid.
Because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala told
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam,
[Silence]
Allah tells the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam that if one of the
mushrikeen seeks sanctuary with you,
then grant him sanctuary
up until he hears the words of Allah.
Meaning until the message of Islam
breaks through to them, you get through
the propaganda, you get through the
misinformation, you punch through the
lies, you punch through the ego until
you get through all of that. When
someone comes to you for a favor, they
are in a vulnerable position.
Is it manipulative? Listen to the
question.
Is it manipulative
that if someone comes to you in need
that you take that opportunity
being that they are in a vulnerable
position and you are in a position of
power over them to use that as leverage
to teach them about Islam. Is that
manipulative?
What is it? Am I manipulating you right
now with my words?
OF COURSE I AM. ALL OF US ARE
MANIPULATORS. That's how we deal with
each other.
But when we say the word manipulation,
it usually has negative connotations.
It's usually manipulation for
nefarious purposes.
But yes, it is manipulative. That's
okay. You manipulate the situation for
the person's own good. Yusuf alayhis
salaam, the prisoners came to him. They
said
Tell us, I had a dream about this, I had
a dream about that. What did he say to
them?
He said
before that, let me tell you about this.
And he gave them an entire
set of verses regarding the oneness of
Allah, the worship of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Was he
using and leveraging the situation and
leveraging their need and their
their their vulnerability in order to
get the message of Islam through to
them? Absolutely, he was.
When I sit with my child and I say,
"Listen, man. Okay, I know you want this
piece of candy. If you leave this now,
we'll do this over here." Am I not
manipulating my child?
I am.
I am manipulating him, but I am
manipulating him for his good, for his
welfare. Human beings, naturally, are
social creatures. And we manipulate each
other
in
the way that we speak, the words that we
choose, the tone that we have, the the
body language, our posturing, what we
say, what we don't say.
But manipulating for nefarious purposes,
that is something the prophets and
messengers are free from.
And so,
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
understands that Thumamah
is a person that has been absolutely
stuffed full of propaganda.
All of the enemies of Islam have bent
this man's ear for years,
for 10, 15 years,
charging him up and gassing him up
against Islam.
But most of what he says, most it's all
lies. It's not real.
So, the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam wanted to break through that
propaganda. What is the best way to do
that?
It is very rare that you can change
something with your words. This is super
rare. You know in the movies,
something happens, and then one of
the characters stands up, and he gives
this very heartfelt speech, and then
everything changes. That's not how the
real world world works.
Very few people will be influenced by
words alone.
Actions are what change people's
perspective.
When they see things, they have to
experience these things.
Right?
And so
he left him for a second day.
He came back the third day.
He's softening him up. Imagine being
tied to a pillar. What did he see during
that time?
While he was in the masjid. I mean, for
me
if you told me, "Hey,
if you want to go back and be in
Thumamah's place, you're going to be
tied to a pillar for 3 days and then you
die after that." I'll take that deal
right now. I'd take that deal. Would you
take that deal?
I mean, that would be a great deal,
right? What was he able to do during
that time? He sat there. He listened to
salah. He listened to the Quran. He
listened to the companions. He watched
them. They watched them deal with each
other. He was there in the depths of
night hearing footsteps of companions
coming at night time to pray.
He was listening to people making their
dua. He was watching
for 3 days.
And so
on the third day he came
and he asked him the same thing. "Ma
taqulu ya Thumamah?
Ma indak ya Thumamah?" So, he said,
"Kama qultu laka."
This time he just says as I told you
before.
So, the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam said,
"Atliqu Thumamah."
Let him go.
So, they let him go.
And immediately he went insarafa ila
an-najlin qaribin min al-masjid.
An-najlin aish an-najlin? An-najlin
manba'un lil ma' tabiyi yukhrijul ma'i
min al-ardh hayk.
Hatha ismuhu najlin.
[Arabic recitation]
bustan. Bustan al-ashjar an-nakhl.
Faghtasala
[Arabic recitation]
When they let Thumamah go,
he went to a
spring very close to the masjid in an in
an orchard, and he bathed, and then he
came back to the masjid, and he said to
the prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam,
"I testify that none is rightfully
worshipped but Allah, and that you are
the messenger of Allah."
Notice, he went and bathed.
Where did he learn that from?
He's sitting in the masjid. This is the
kind of things the companions are
learning in the masjid.
He didn't have to be told. He
immediately went cuz he understands. You
become Muslim, you bathe. This is how it
works.
And so,
he said to the prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam,
[Silence]
He said, "Your face
was previously the most
repulsive face to me. I hated it the
most.
And now I love no face more than yours.
And your religion was the repulsive
religion to me.
And now your religion is the most
beloved religion to me.
And your city was the most repulsive
city to me. And it has now become the
most beloved of cities to me.
Now notice Thumamah, he could have said
that before that he wanted to become
Muslim, right? And they would have let
him go.
But no, he waited until they let him go
on his own.
Look at that precedence.
Look at that izzat e nafs that he had.
So that he would not be confused with
someone who is accepting Islam out of
desperation.
And so
he then said to the prophet
He said, "I was going to Umrah when
I was picked up by your troops.
What should I do?"
[Silence]
Look at how strategic this became. When
he went to Mecca, they started making
fun of him.
Now
this is not a regular guy. You can't
just
throw him around. You can't step on his
toes. This is a chieftain. He has
thousands of armed men ready to die at
his feet to defend his honor.
And so, they kind of passively
aggressively kind of start poking fun of
him. They said, "Asabota?"
Asab it in the language of the people of
Mecca, the Kuffar of Mecca at the time
meant that you abandoned the way of your
forefathers
and you let your ancestors down. That's
what Asabota means.
And he said, "No. I accepted Islam
with Muhammad the messenger of Allah.
And not only that, but you all will not
receive one grain
until Muhammad allows it."
And he prohibited any importation of
grain into the entirety of Mecca
as abandoning with the prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam. And he was
absolutely strategic in the conquest of
Mecca because what year was the conquest
of Mecca?
Seven after Hijra. Some mention eight
after Hijra. It happened right on the
heels of the Islam of Thumamah.
And not only that, but in Hurub
al-Ridda, during the battle of
al-Yamamah
between Musaylimah and Khalid ibn
al-Walid,
Thumamah was instrumental
in the conquest of al-Yamamah and the
reopening of al-Yamamah.
It's almost, you could say, it couldn't
have been done without Thumamah.
Radiyallahu anhu. And he exhibited
extreme bravery
during the battles and Hurub of al-Ridda
after the prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam's death.
Nas'al Allah Subhana wa Ta'ala
[Silence]
Oh, yeah.